let me start by saying
uh how great you did in the movie and uh
and how great the film is
um i'm assuming when when you sign on to
something like this and you look at a
script of this quality i'm assuming
going in you're like this
could be a special film yeah absolutely
uh the reason i signed on was because i
knew how much
the conversation resonated with me and
if done right
i thought that i knew the potential of
the project
i didn't actually know until much later
when i saw the project and i saw in the
time in which it came out
um i was like wow this is uh
this is something how lucky could we
have gotten
to have been able to to say something
like this to create this kind of
art in this particular time so yeah i
thought i knew
uh but i really didn't you know i was
pleasantly surprised
the film takes place in 64. but it just
unfortunately it's just as relevant
today
and um i am curious do you feel like as
a society
that the last year uh with everything
that's been going on
that we are god willing at like a
transition moment
or do you think that the struggle that
has been going on for decades
is going to continue for decades you
know i don't know it's it's a catch-22
because we've been at this
transitional period in the 60s with the
civil rights movement we've been there
in the 90s
um dealing with police brutality and a
lot of it was sparked off you know in
the l.a riots with rodney king
uh you know we've been here before and
and that's why
i keep thinking that the goal is not
a monetary action or a moment of
of deviation from the normal it's
consistency of change
change happens when there's consistency
of differences to a point where
equity inequality for all is normal to
the point where it looks ridiculous
if you know people aren't getting equal
wages because of the color their skin or
the demographic
where they're from like that that has to
be ridiculous it's ridiculous to us
we get it so i don't know all i can say
is that i hope that we are the precipice
of
of the continuation of these efforts
that will
generate and create lasting and
consistent change because i see the art
coming out i see the people galvanized
and moving i see the work being done
we just need to maintain for for us all
to keep moving forward and i
feel hopeful that we can do that
when you are playing a role like this
and you're working with such
other gifted performers are you staying
in character
a lot more when you're on set or are you
sort of like
going in and out you know what i mean
yeah so i stay focused 24 7 with my work
with this particular
role uh i stayed in voice so i kind of
step in and step
out with my mental check-ins i step out
enough
that you know regina comes up and has a
note we're trying to get somewhere i
know enough to
to watch and figure out where to shift
and move but when i'm in the character
and i'm doing my performance i'm in it
thinking about
how can i continue to be more and more
and more like this person so i'm
constantly doing work
i i never let up for a second and i
never get distracted
i i'm imagining one of the things that i
really loved about your performance is i
could see this
in certain scenes like the seething
anger almost below the surface
um and i'm just i'm obviously i'm sure
was there one thing or a few things that
you looked at to prepare
to play you know the role or like could
you sort of talk about that preparation
i think that when you saw the seething
anger in those films
i probably just had like cramps that day
bro you know it's probably like going
through something
and i just i don't know i pulled a
muscle
no i looked at um a lot of his uh
videos from the past and yes from from
his debates uh
one that i speak about all the time
where it came to
uh him debating a racist governor of
georgia at the time lester maddox
maddox on the duke cabot show his
mannerisms his composure even how he
moved
i used all of that to influence uh
my scene with beau bridges when he was
playing mr carlton in the beginning
um i used all of it to to help
sort of help me drive through what his
emotional journey was
and his purpose was for this uh
particular night and and
what he had to say why he was there and
why why he wanted to say it
uh i'm obviously incredibly excited
about um
you know some other superhero movie that
might be coming up
what super movie are you talking about i
have no idea
something with dwayne johnson maybe
yeah man uh i am uh
how much are they telling you about the
arc of the character and ultimately
what you'll be doing and how much is it
sort of like oh dwayne johnson's
superheroes dc yeah i'm in
yeah exactly uh so we we discuss
a lot about the arc of the character and
um
that's all i can say on that
[Laughter]
right well i guess what i mean is though
do you know
ultimately like what they want you to do
in the dc universe
or is it sort of like you're just
signing on to this one thing
i the connection broke up i couldn't
hear i
you know oh man
you said something about the rock though
and yes
well i'm sworn to secrecy but yeah
working with the rock man this is this
is gonna be awesome
uh man i i'm a real i'm a big fan of
the moves he's made in his career and
how he got to where he's at
i mean to you got to be a smart brother
and
i'm talking about a hustling brother to
to make it up to the top of the ranks to
become the biggest action star in the
world
and he's done so with really smart
strategic moves so i can't wait to just
kind of pick his brain on a couple of
things i already been asking him about
the nutritional stuff he
you got me set right there but um you
know
i like to surround myself with uh real
mavericks who are teachers and i feel
like being around
him i'll be able to to learn a little
bit of how to manage that hustle
just the way i learned a lot from you
know regina on this project in terms of
how she handled herself
as a leader on set and being able to
manage the full team man it was a
fantastic education watching her work
on that note i gotta go i'm also looking
forward to sitting on a hill season two
thank you i i would talk about it but
anyway i'm out of time but listen
i've been a fan of your work for a while
i wish you nothing but the best thank
you so much steve thank you